where they're going to meet physically
next week is Bletchley Park indeed um
because of course you know they're
having the UK AI Summit um although
actually there won't be you know
there'll be quite a lot of tech
representation there um but not across
the board one of the very odd things
about next week's Summit is you have the
big tech companies represented big time
but actually very few of the British um
AI companies represented there so that's
another Oddity but it indicates you know
how the global engines of growth are
developing right now um you know if you
ask me what can government do about AI
um you know one of the problems is that
the what's happened in the AI sphere in
the last year which is really a shift
from what people call symbolic systems
of AI which write Co write code and
rules about how AI is going to
operate
preemptively as opposed to statistical
systems of AI like chat gbt um or you
know based on neural um natur language
processing models which essentially
operate not by pre-writing
code but by essentially mimicking humans
by absorb observing them on massive
scale that shift has been driven by
about 200 people so there's about 200
people who are really the key players in
this space right now in the west I'm
leaving outside China
um as it happens the UK has played a key
role in actually generating some of
those 200 people someone like Jeff
Hinton who was at Kings um in Cambridge
you know is called The Godfather of AI
he's been critical to Google's
development in that field some like
Demis hasis um who created a deep mind
again is critical so you've got quite a
few Brits in there although a lot of
them have migrated to the US um but it's
literally only 200 people and and by the
way their salaries are going up through
the roof right now
unsurprisingly um and there's really
only four companies that are driving the
base systems not the applications but
the Bas systems um and that means that
those people understand it and almost
nobody else does there's a huge gap in
understanding and there's almost no one
in Congress who has the foggiest idea
how these systems really work um
Congress in 2016 had more talk show
radio hosts than it had scientists in
Congress true fact and scientists in
America were so horrified by that fact
that they actually went out and created
a political action group to recruit more
scientists to get involved in politics
um to my knowledge the UK doesn't even
have a political action group and I
don't know how many scientists there are
in the house of parliament but I bet my
bottom dollar there aren't that many um
and that's a problem so do I trust
governments to regulate it no do I trust
um the AI companies themselves to
regulate it probably no not either but
it's is going to need some kind of
Regulation and control going forward
because if not that's quite scary
because I think it was Jeff Hinton who
who who raised the flag just a couple of
months ago saying essentially alarm
alarm yeah I mean if any of you have got
you know time in your hands to spare and
want to understand this um Jeff Hinton
gave a brilliant interview at Kings
actually on this issue where he
expressed his concerns not just about
the bigger existential risks that the
machines might go mad and take over the
world and kill us all but actually the
very immediate risk that you know in the
2024 election we may have an absolute PR
proliferation of deep fakes and
manipulation that way um and that's
going to be a top topic to discussion
next week in Bletchley Park um and there
are things you can do about that I mean
I was with yal harui today um the author
of sapiens you know who comes out with
some really good sensible ideas like you
know you could use a lot of existing
legislation to try and control AI
counterfeiting that's really well
established in the financial sphere you
can't counterfeit money you could very
easily and this is her's 's idea um you
could very easily apply that to the AI
sector and say you can't counterfeit
humans you can't create fake fake Bots
or you will go to jail you don't need
new laws you just take the ones from the
financial world and apply them into the
um you know Tech sector you could use um
you know issues around watermarking and
require content to be watermarked they
they've talked about that already and
I'm think probably next week they'll
come out with something on that um to
mean that people can check whether the
provence is real or not so the things
you can do around all of that you know
quite immediately um which would be you
know at least progress but the big
question is um you know how are you
going to stop the incipient capabilities
that are emerging so aside from Jeff
hinton's video um tristam Harris who is
one of the West Coast techies who has
spent the last decade walking warning
about social media he was previously at
Google designing social media apps he's
now produced a fantastic video that
explains what's going on in Ai and why
some of it's quite so dangerous the
thing I would stress though is I'm not
in the camp of people who say it's all
Dem disaster at all because just being
in Kings in Cambridge in the last three
weeks I mean it is stunning what AI is
doing for research in terms of biolog
biological research I mean absolutely
unimaginable
leaps in research capabilities in terms
of Neuroscience in terms of biology in
terms of engineering I mean the way that
people at Cambridge and I'm dare say the
other universities as well are using ai
ai tools for positive research benefits
right now would blow your mind so that's
a good side and we have to find out a
way to harness that in a positive
way